last census said there is something over
400,000 Irish citizens people born in
the Republic of Ireland living in the UK
and you know the free movement of
people's between between those borders
no passport required can vote don't have
any problems whatsoever without a change
once we leave the EU the Ridgid had
their work well no the answer is the
island was part of this country hold on
a minute what well uh well yes I guess
it was until 921 you know Harlem was a
part of this country and that's why we
had the free movement and no restriction
and it's been there you know the best
part of a hundred years the okay so that
would rather difficult doubt apply to
Indians then who are who are part of
this country until 1947 one of the
difficulties that we have here is that
if you have free movement with Ireland
and Ireland has stayed part of the
European Union and we haven't then we've
got a rethink battle mini it is a very
difficult problem I'm what apply to the
Scots I mean a vote for it when I died I
don't they will but yes it would I mean
you know when you think about it who's
in charge of British immigration policy
I mean at the moment Romania are dishing
out hundreds of passports every week to
Moldovans so in effect it is the
Romanian Parliament who can decide who
can come to Britain we could face that
problem with Arlen